(kookaburra laughing)
- What in the world is that,
it's like a gremlin got out.
- It's the kookaburra!
- It's a kookaburra, I can't
say with your cool accent.
- I can do it, I actually
practiced doing him last.
- Wait, can you harmonize with that?
If we played it, could you
harmonize with the kookaburra?
- Mm, yeah.
- Okay, Robert, Bindi, can
you bring the bird out?
I'm gonna harmonize with Kristin.
(audience applause)
- We're gonna harmonize.
We're gonna do it.
We can do it.
- This is so exciting!
- Hey, y'all!
- So good to see you, how you doing?
- Look it's my size!
(Robert laughs)
- All right, he might
not make a sound now.
But, hey can we play it?
We're gonna try, this is the sound.
- This is it, okay.
(kookaburra calling)
(Kristin coos)
(Kelly laughs)
- [Bindi] I love you!
(Kristin coos)
- He doesn't know what to think.
- This is like most of my
boyfriends, they're scared of me.